[Musique]
bonsoir à tous leurs de votre journal de
l'afrique soit il est à bienvenue à la
une de l'actualité de ce soir ce bras de
fer qui se poursuit entre tunis et rabat
après avoir refusé de participer au
championnat nord africains de karaté le
royaume chérifien n'en verra pas non
plus son équipe de volley ball aux
prochaines compétitions prévues à tunis
on viendra sur ces brouilles plus en
détail dans ce journal avec vincent ghsr
les notre invité
les avocats de poules chéri à bas les
convoque la presse est accusé d'entente
avec une puissance étrangère la
militante est en prison depuis son
retour du mali elle s'y était rendu pour
négocier la libération et 49 soldats
ivoiriens détenus
et puis la faire paul pogba vue de
guinée la presse nationale s'en est
emparé quelques grands titres et
consacrent leur une malick dia fut t on
à coup qu'il est certaine vous le verrez
plus en détail dans ce journal
je vous le disais à l'instant donc le
bras de fer qui oppose tunis et rabat la
fédération marocaine des droits du
consommateur met à son tour la pression
l'organisation appelé au boycott de
produits en provenance de tunisie le
royaume voit rouge depuis l'accueil très
officiel accordé au leader du front
polisario brahim rallye a été reçu par
le président saïd en personne tout en
symbole qu'a me nédélec
la tension entre le maroc et la tunisie
ne faiblit pas et se fait sentir dans
plusieurs secteurs la fédération
marocaine des droits du consommateur
appel à un boycott
la fédération marocaine des droits du
consommateur condamne les positions
hostiles du chef de l'état tunisien à
l'égard de la cause nationale en
recevant à séparatiste est un terroriste
à la tête d'un et papy ctif la
conséquence d'une crise déclenchée entre
les deux pays ce week end lors du sommet
afrique japon à tunis le président
tunisien kaïs sayed s'est rendue à
l'aéroport pour recevoir personnellement
brahim ghali le chef du front polisario
qui revendique l'autonomie du sahara
occidental pour ba le territoire est
marocain et son autonomie n'est pas
reconnu par la majorité des pays ni par
l'onu mais est reconnu par l'union
africaine et l'algérie ces derniers
jours les ambassadeurs respectifs des
deux pays ont été rappelés mercredi le
maroc a annoncé que son équipe de volley
ball ne participera pas aux prochaines
compétitions prévues à tunis
il y a une grande tension maintenant il
ya une tentative d'utiliser cette crise
pour aggraver la situation diplomatique
et politique entre deux pays frères et
amis il est donc important de calmer la
situation
le maroc souhaite que ses alliés et une
position claire sur le statut du sahara
occidental
rabat propose un plan d'autonomie sous
sa souveraineté une initiative récité
par brahim ghali qui demande un
référendum d'autodétermination sous
l'égide de l'onu
notre invité ce soir c'est vous vincent
ghsr bonsoir à vous vous êtes chercheur
à l'institut de recherches et d'études
sur le monde arabe et musulman vous avez
notamment publié plusieurs ouvrages sur
les pays du maghreb merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation france 24 vincent
ghsr jusqu'où peut aller cette brouille
entre tunis et rabat écoutez elle peut
aller encore plus loin notamment on voit
aujourd'hui il ya un véritable mouvement
au maroc de boycott qui s'organise à
partir entre guillemets d'organisations
de la société civile en revanche du côté
tunisien il ya quand même une gêne
pourquoi tout simplement parce que
beaucoup de tunisiens ne sont pas très
contents de cette brouille pour eux
c'est une rupture ou dû à une évolution
inquiétante par rapport à ce qu'on
appelait en tunisie la diplomatie ou la
neutralité positive de la ligne
diplomatique tunisienne et aimerait bien
voir la tunisie revenir dans ce giron
classique de la neutralité positive où
elle était une grande médiatrice entre
l'algérie et le maroc alors que là elle
apparaît un peu trop dans le clan de
l'algérie donc du côté de tunis en tout
cas il ya quand même beaucoup de
pression interne pour que cai saïd
reviennent sur cette politique de
neutralité positive alors justement
pourquoi est-ce que la tunisie a
soudainement changé de position pourquoi
avoir rompu avec cette neutralité
maintenant bonne question d'abord une
situation très difficile sur le plan
économique un la tunisie connais des des
pénuries de produits
essentiels comme le sucre comme le café
comme comme je dirais même la farine tu
as l'air des produits qui sont des
produits alimentaires de base elle
connaît des problèmes
d'approvisionnement en gaz or vous savez
de ce point de vue là l'algérie est un
pays gazier est impliqué susceptibles de
fonnière de gaz et puis il ya aussi une
dimension il ya deux autres dimensions
une dimension aussi de d'isolement de la
tunisie diplomatique très très fortes
pressions américaines pour revenir à une
forme de normalité démocratique
et puis les deux grands alliés de la
tunisie qui est quand même l'egypte et
les émirats arabes unis c'est pas qu'ils
l'ont lâché mais ils ont pris leur
distance donc elle est quand même isolé
ce qu'ils incitent quelque part un peu à
se jeter dans les bras de son voisin à
la fois inquiétant mais rassurant qui
est l'algérie donc le président algérien
le président tebboune n'at-il oui un
rôle dans ce basculement mais bien sûr
bien sûr savez là bien sûr que l'algérie
à une diplomatie active pour amener
aït-saïd à faire cette invitation du
leader du polisario pourquoi parce que
l'algérie a peur d'un deuxième maroc sur
sa frontière est en deux mots l'algérie
ne veux pas que la tunisie se marre aux
kings devienne un deuxième maroc c'est à
dire un pays qui seraient trop près d'un
certain nombre de pays du golfe comme
les émirats et l'arabie saoudite est
aussi faut-il le dire la question
israélo-palestinienne pas et ça aide n'a
jamais caché son hostilité à l'égard de
ce qu'on pourrait appeler une politique
de normalisation
l'algérie est totalement sur cette ligne
or de ce point de vue là l'algérie veut
un allié sûr qu'ils ne se rapproche pas
trop de l'état d'israël et là c'est
clair que c'est un grand différent
puisque les deux alliés de la tunisie
qui étaient les émirats et l'egypte
reconnaissent aujourd'hui israël alors
que kyle saïd ne veut toujours pas
reconnaître cet état est de ce point de
vue là l'algérie donc fait une alliance
de raison avec une tunisie car elle a
peur vraiment d'un deuxième maroc sur sa
frontière est récent et sanctionnent
justement maroc pour avoir paraphé ces
accords d'un bram
oui oui effectivement est actuellement
on voit bien que mais le maroc n'est pas
isolé c'est ça la grande différence et
qu'alors que la tunisie est de plus en
plus isolé et notamment notamment du
point de vue des etats-unis là des états
unis n'ont jamais été aussi durs à
l'égard de la tunisie même à l'époque où
ben ali était connaissent et pourtant il
dérive autoritaire alors là il faut
s'interroger est-ce qu'on va aller là à
les voir la tunisie s'enfermer sur un
axe qu'on pourrait dire sinon russe et
algérien où est ce qu'on va recréer une
forme de médiation avec la tunisie pour
effectivement espérer non pas forcément
qu'elle devienne un deuxième maroc mais
qu'elle renoue avec ce principe de
diplomatie positive de neutralité
positive qui avait été la ligne
diplomatique suivi par bourguiba ben ali
marzouki n'est encore davantage par beji
caïd sebsi qui est un des pères de la
politique étrangère tunisienne et je
reviens sur le maroc vincent ghsr vous
dites que le maroc n'est pas tout à fait
isolé leur peut-être pas sur la scène
internationale mais au sens du mât red
même est ce qu'il n'est pas en train de
s'isoler justement à se fâcher avec le
voisin algérien maintenant avec la
tunisie qui avait été un pays à 1000
clair le maroc s'est isolé mais le maroc
a déjà développé un système d'alliances
si je puis dire qui enjambe à la fois
l'algérie et la tunisie en clairement
aujourd'hui menant et des accords de
coopération et même une intégration
quasiment avec d'autres pays arabes par
exemple les pays du golfe puisque le
maroc fait partie du conseil de
coopération du golfe
le maroc mène aujourd'hui même des
opérations militaires avec les pays du
golfe c'est à dire que le maroc bien sûr
et soucis sociaux de sa politique
maghrébine mais est soucieux aussi de
son intégration dans le monde arabe et
aujourd'hui il ne manque pas d'alliés
même l'egypte même l'egypte aujourd'hui
semble approuver la position marocaine
et j'ai cru entendre que l'egypte aussi
avait mené une brique un bon une forme
de boycott sportif à l'égard de la
tunisie l'egypte qui est pourtant le
principal allié de kai eide qui a
soutenu les coups d'état et qui
aujourd'hui rejoindre une position
marocaine ce qui veut dire que le maroc
de toute façon elle soutien américain à
l soutien saoudien elle soutient émirati
et donc de ce point de vue là son
isolement diplomatique est moindre que
celui de la tunisie et beaucoup d'élites
tunisienne qui pourtant ne veulent pas
blâmer kaïs saïd qui considère qu'il a
eu quand même un acte de courage lui
demande quand même de faire preuve de
raison et de venir dont revenir à ce bon
pratique de la diplomatie positive de la
neutralité positive c'est-à-dire être le
médiateur au sein du maghreb voire même
au-delà au sein de l'union africaine
merci beaucoup vincent gc remercie
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions à abidjan les avocats de
poules schering mal et passe à
l'offensive et dénonce un complot visant
leurs clients que les militants de la
société civile est incarcéré depuis son
retour du mali elle s'était rendue sur
place pour tenter d'obtenir la
libération des 49 soldats ivoiriens
détenu depuis le 10 juillet dernier elle
sadia mans dur nous en dit plus
la sphère poule ciré bâ les rencontres
la sphère des cars neufs soldats
ivoiriens détenus au mali
tout commence le 3 août lorsque
l'activité est arrêtée à l'aéroport
d'abidjan de son retour du mahdi elle
est relâchée mais son téléphone portable
et son passeport sont confisqués le 22
août on l'appelle pour qu'elle vienne
récupérer ses affaires à la place elle
est interrogée et mises en garde à vue
dans la foulée
sa maison est perquisitionné son mandat
pour ses avocats c'est un scandale cette
affaire est malhonnête et la procédure
porte atteinte aux droits de leur
cliente mais pour le procureur de la
république richard adou cette
incarcération est justifié pour lui
lorsque pulchérie balle et se rend au
mali pour trouver une solution
diplomatique pour libérer les soldats
elle sous-entend que le gouvernement ne
le fait pas ce matin ses avocats ont
tenu une conférence de presse au siège
de l'association on écoute m eric sacchi
suffirait-il
d'allemagne et il est venu pour que cela
constitue une honte un avec une
puissance étrangère ou avec les agents
d'une puissance étrangère nous le
croyons nous que le croyais autre à
celui des fractions de trouver leur
public il est curieux de constater pour
que le mot d'ordre invitant à la revoir
encore moins à participer à une
manifestation quelconque n'a été lancé
par leurs clients à la population
l'indoor délétère le climat pour ses
avocats pour gérer balles et n'a
rencontré aucune autorité détrôner
somalienne ni les prisonniers ce n'est
pas la première fois que l'activiste est
incarcéré à abidjan en 2020 elle a été
arrêté et mis en prison pour avoir
appelé à manifester contre la
candidature d'alassane ouattara
concernant l'écart 9 soldats ivoiriens
les négociations sont toujours en cours
selon les autorités ivoiriennes
plusieurs médiations sachez le sont en
cours pour obtenir la libération de ses
49 soldats dont sept du togo et de
leaders religieux malien voilà ce qu'on
peut dire pour l'heure sur ce dossier le
nom de paul pogba aurez vous le savez
depuis plusieurs jours associée une
sombre affaire d'extorsion son frère
aîné mathias est impliqué le parquet de
paris a ouvert une enquête ces
accusations font aussi réagir en guinée
le pays d'origine du joueur il y était
d'ailleurs en juin dernier c'est à ce
moment là que ces images avaient été à
tourner la presse nationale s'est elle
aussi emparée de cette affaire malika
diakité est à conakry pour france 24
c'est une affaire qui a fait grand bruit
ici à conakry et la pressant dans paris
comme l'hebdomadaire à la lance dans sa
publication de semer crédit qui titrent
les frais prob à la violence en public
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de
certains journalistes sportifs du pays
pour eux cette affaire vient entacher
l'image d'une famille réunie que renvoya
les frais boba ne peut pas imaginer un
seul instant que cela puisse arriver
notamment sans cette famille là qui est
toujours assez soudé alors qu'une mère 4
juillet et ainsi ses trois enfants voilà
donc assez improbable surprise au nom du
savoir qu'il n'est pas aujourd'hui sont
en train du centre et centre du chili on
est un peu choqués on est un peu surpris
de ce qui se passe parce que ça vient
quand même de deux frères on avait
tellement les petites de les voir
ensemble tous les trois fleurantins
mathias épaules quand ils sont ensemble
ils donnent vraiment cette envie de
vivre et bien vivre les frais pogba sont
très bien connus ici en guinée mathias
pogba a déjà fait deux sélections avec
le syli national le nom de la sélection
guinéenne de football en juin dernier
pour le combat avait participé à un
match de charité ici à conakry où il
avait été accueilli par des milliers de
guinéens vous l'aurez compris la ferme
au ballet bien suivi et si en guinée le
pays d'origine
c'est la fin de cette première édition
du journal de l'afrique paris direct
continuent-ils on se retrouve dans 45
minutes au total